en este vídeo me gustaría suponer que
tenemos un monopolio no sé un monopolio
de lo que sea bueno de hecho en este
caso es un monopolio de naranjas y
además en este monopolio ya tenemos la
curva de demanda que tenemos en el
mercado y lo que yo me voy a preguntar
en esta ocasión es cómo puedo obtener
una ganancia que sea máxima bueno antes
de pensar en ganancias sería bueno que
pensáramos en el total de ingresos de
ciertas cantidades en el margen de esos
ingresos de esas cantidades y además
compararlas con el margen del costo de
esas cantidades de naranjas y bueno con
esta comparación lo que yo voy a obtener
es la cantidad de naranjas que debo de
producir para obtener mi mayor ganancia
ahora fijémonos en el ingreso total si
yo no produzco naranjas pues por lo
tanto yo no tengo ingreso entonces mi
curva de ingresos pasa por el origen a
cero naranjas no tengo nada de ingreso
ahora bien qué pasa si yo tengo una
unidad y ojo las unidades están dadas en
toneladas por día es decir yo tengo una
unidad por lo tanto tengo una tonelada y
si además recordamos que el ingreso es
lo mismo que el precio por la
que vamos a vender entonces voy a
obtener el área de este rectángulo o
dicho de otra manera una tonelada que
multiplica a cinco mil pesos por
tonelada de lo que obtengo cinco mil
pesos
ingreso es igual a costo por cantidad y
ahora si yo pongo este punto en mi plano
donde comparó el ingreso que está dado
por cierto en miles de pesos con la
cantidad de naranjas que están dadas en
toneladas entonces voy a obtener este
punto que acabo de poner muy bien
entonces si yo produzco una tonelada de
naranjas obtengo el precio de cinco mil
pesos por tonelada ahora qué pasa si yo
produzco dos toneladas de naranjas a
pues entonces se venden fíjense muy bien
aquí está el punto entonces se van a
vender en cuatro mil pesos por tonelada
entonces obtengo este rectángulo que voy
a sombrear justo en este momento dos
toneladas por cuatro mil pesos por cada
tonelada voy a obtener ocho mil pesos de
ganancia entonces vamos a ponerlo para
dos toneladas voy a obtener ocho mil
pesos si por aquí es 7.5 por acá va a
ser 8 mil y va a ser
este punto de aquí y de manera análoga
para tres toneladas es más si yo quiero
saber cuántas toneladas voy a vender
cuando yo tengo el precio de tres mil
pesos por tonelada van a ser tres
toneladas dándome el área de este
rectángulo que yo tengo aquí es decir
tres toneladas por tres mil pesos por
tonelada yo obtengo nueve mil pesos de
ganancia entonces es este punto que está
justo por aquí y de la misma manera
cuando yo quiero vender a un precio de
dos mil pesos por tonelada entonces lo
más que puedo vender son cuatro
toneladas dándome así un ingreso de esta
área que yo tengo aquí y dos por cuatro
son ocho mil pesos de ingreso entonces
vamos a poner el punto es justo este
punto de aquí regresamos a ocho mil
pesos de ingreso está igual a la misma
altura que este otro punto y bueno qué
pasa ahora si yo tengo cinco toneladas
naranjas si yo tengo cinco toneladas de
naranjas fíjense en la gráfica
yo puedo vender cada una de esas
toneladas a mil pesos obteniendo un
ingreso de cinco mil pesos y al poner el
punto en la gráfica de la derecha yo voy
a obtener este
5 estaría justo aquí y bueno ya por
último qué va a pasar si yo tengo 6
toneladas si yo tengo 69 toneladas el
precio es tan bajo que podemos decir que
es casi cero es decir son gratis
por lo tanto 6 por 0 obtengo 0 pesos de
ingreso es decir no obtengo ingreso y me
da este punto de aquí
ahora bien fijémonos en la gráfica de la
derecha ya reconocen este tipo de
gráfica en efecto es una parábola es una
parábola que abre hacia abajo y si
usamos un poco la idea de continuidad se
va a ver una parábola muy parecida a
esta que estoy dibujando muy bien
perfecto ya tenemos nuestra parábola y
bueno si nosotros tratamos de ponerle un
poco de matemáticas y ecuaciones el
asunto que voy a obtener bueno voy a
tratar de hacer primero la ecuación de
esta recta esta recta tiene como
ecuación estamos comparando el precio
con la cantidad y por lo tanto la
ecuación de esta recta va a ser 6 menos
la cantidad o dicho de otra manera si lo
quieren ver de la forma y es igual a m x
+ b esto es lo mismo que decir que el
precio
es igual a menos la cantidad menos q más
6 estas dos ecuaciones son la misma
solamente que escrita de una manera
distinta y ojo este 6 sale porque corta
mi recta al valor de 6 en el eje del
precio y está pendiente de menos 1 sale
porque cuando aumentó la producción en
una tonelada el precio baja en mil pesos
o dicho de otra manera si el precio baja
mil pesos es porque mi producción ha
aumentado una tonelada y bueno ahora
para sacar la ecuación de la gráfica de
la derecha yo tengo que recordar que el
ingreso es igual al precio por la
cantidad pero el precio ya lo tenemos
como una función de la cantidad es justa
la línea recta que acabamos de sacar la
ecuación de la recta que acabamos de
sacar por lo tanto si sustituimos el
precio voy a obtener que el ingreso
total es igual al precio que por cierto
era menos 6 que multiplica a q y ahora
si yo distribuyó la q voy a obtener que
el ingreso total es igual a menos q
cuadrada q por q va a quedar cuadrada
menos q cuadrada más
y esto ya se ve claramente que es una
parábola que abre hacia abajo y que pasa
por el origen es una palabra que abre
hacia abajo por el signo negativo y que
pasa por el cero porque si nosotros
sustituimos acá por cero vamos a obtener
que el ingreso total es cero y bueno yo
creo que por este vídeo los voy a dejar
mi intención no es hacer vídeos muy
largos en esta ocasión sin embargo en el
siguiente vídeo voy a ver lo que es el
margen de ingreso y vamos a recordar un
poco lo que es el margen de ingreso de
una buena vez el margen de ingresos lo
defino como el cambio en el ingreso
total el cambio en el ingreso total
dividido entre el cambio en la cantidad
esto dicho de una manera mucho más
geométrica es la pendiente de la recta
tangente en un punto de mi curva del
ingreso total y recuerden que cuando
nosotros pensamos en rectas tangentes en
pendientes de rectas tangentes estamos
pensando en derivadas por lo tanto en
cálculo sin embargo en el próximo vídeo
lo que voy a intentar es hacer una
aproximación
todo algebraico es decir lo que nosotros
vamos a buscar es la pendiente de la
recta tangente en un punto y para esto
lo que voy a ocupar o lo que voy a
necesitar es hablar de un cambio muy
pequeño de un cambio casi instantáneo
por lo tanto por ello hablar del margen
de ingresos necesito fijarme en el
cambio en el cambio que yo voy a obtener
en el ingreso total a comparación del
cambio que yo voy a obtener en la
cantidad es decir lo que vamos a
intentar es encontrar el cambio
instantáneo o dicho de otra manera la
pendiente de la recta tangente en un
punto de mi curva del ingreso total pero
eso lo veremos en el siguiente vídeo